so jeff bezos is about to get bailed out
it hasn't been confirmed yet by the
senate where do you get these stories
from son this [ __ ] is big bro
so jeff bezos about to get a 10 billion
dollar bailout for his
failed um trip to the moon
people start businesses every day that
fail keep keep going
people keep going how many restaurants
shut down during the do i need to set it
up or everybody knows what i'm talking
about i have no idea about it
okay so i don't need no horizons i have
a hunch
i have a hunch about this after you
don't strongly about this
guy i know he got this one i know he got
this one
[ __ ] bailout so check this so blue
horizon
was uh jeff bezos of spacex right and
they were both
fighting for a government contract for
about 10 billion dollars which is like
the new [ __ ]
like a frontier endless frontier endless
frontier act or whatever it was
basically like yo
here's some money smart [ __ ]
make some [ __ ] and hopefully we can use
it boom
um spacex won because their bid
for the contract was like way less i
believe you could look it up just to
make sure but i believe it was way less
bezos company fails failed they spent
635 000 lobbying congress to let them do
it
there was one [ __ ] contract out and
now they're proposing another bill
to let there be two contracts so that he
doesn't have to lose out on that 10
billion for blue horizon
now there's two ways to look at it one
is you lost fam now keep going wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
one second how did he lose 10 billion he
just lost the contract he lost out on
the contract
but he never spent that money yet uh no
but i think he spent a certain amount of
money
on blue horizon and building that up
okay to get to the point where they
could go we could do it for this amount
so he put money up before it blew
horizon he just didn't win the bid
okay i'll go okay right so um i can
i can read my notes here if you want go
ahead it's fine
no no we're all the same page now i'm
just going all right basil space flight
company blue
you know you could add these to the
notes
blue origin blue origin my bad it's good
blue or it's not even
oh my god where you sound like have a
hunch
in your life yeah but i'm not from space
if i was from space i know some [ __ ]
about it i think it's tricky
you might be from space bro i'll be
completely honest yeah i might be dogs
whatever you and elon um basically who
gives a [ __ ] is blue origin
anyway um isn't that [ __ ] up that he
gets bailed out
yo if your business failed it failed
yeah wait do you all know what i'm
talking about or not
no enough nobody knows what you talking
about
yeah he is they just making
[Laughter]
it was super slick it was a little like
you didn't even notice it if you didn't
catch it you didn't see it
but that would hurt my testicle the most
well my testicles are not ready for that
little slappy tapping
okay go i can't stare at this sandwich
no more so that [ __ ] looks so delicious
my stomach is grumbling
oh so you watching my kicks
look everybody i got lost i was gonna
say oh my gosh it looks so good
it's amazing i want to [ __ ] where the
egg and the cheese is all right
it's right in front of me so you look at
it
[Music]
go go yo i understand if you need to
bail out like we have bankruptcy laws in
america
ink to encourage capitalism yup but if
we're not bailing out every [ __ ]
restaurant that failed you know how many
things you
how many businesses you could fail out
uh bail out for 10 billion and we're all
about small business in america right
so instead of bailing them out letting
their restaurants whatever stores
crumble during corona economy crumbling
during corona
unemployment all-time high you bail out
the richest human being in the world
maybe second now
he gets 10 billion i don't give a [ __ ]
yo if pepsi
it fails and they have [ __ ] crystal
pepsi they're not like oh hey here's
money for crystal pepsi
nah you're still good you're good and i
i can also even understand a bank is too
big to fail
i can understand that airline is too big
to fail because if those go away we're
all [ __ ] but a space company ain't too
big to be able to
originally we don't give a [ __ ] we're
fine without it we didn't know it
existed until this moment okay al got a
different argument because
if we don't bail him out then he's going
to pay us back by being like oh yeah you
thought you get your
packages are going to come in two days
[ __ ] it three days now
i'm not good i'm not right
yeah he said pack what the packy but um
it's gonna come in respectfully said you
watched
[Laughter]
what the farmers are about okay so you
think you're not gonna give us our
packages
yeah he'll tell you he'll take it out on
us the [ __ ] spent 8.5 billion on
mgm
8.5 you know mgm yeah the movie studio
or whatever
8.5 yeah dramatically
he said it they gave me a look too like
yeah
it's 8.5 i don't even even know about
8.5 your trunk doesn't even close
[Applause]
oh look at his space travel [ __ ] nerd
you're a gay nerd
[Laughter]
oh my god he's like hold up let me check
you always watching the jetsons and
technically it's not possible for origin
blue origin to work
yeah you saw him run out of information
on the jetsons because you know he never
seen that show in his [ __ ] life
because we got self-flying cars already
coming am i right let's go
that's an alliance
all right one more topic cause i gotta
eat something i'm starving
go say the topic you've been dying to
[ __ ] say you [ __ ] dork
don't hit the same
oh
baby new york i'm about to go eat right
now
i'm gonna let you i'ma let you